bu dallar kaybolanlardır ilk başlığımız
bulmak ve kaybolmak
Ne mutlu o Bulut kaybolanlara
[Müzik]
Bir şeyin eksik
ol aramaktan müstağni değildir her buluş
Muhakkak bir arayışla mümkündür ancak
bazı araçların biz farkında değilizdir
Bu bilinçaltı seviyesinde seyretmesinden
de kaynaklı olabilir tamamen bütün
dünyamızı doldurduğu için de olabilir ne
demek istiyorum
sokağa çıksak desek ki
Ey insanlar bir insanın yaşaması için
gerekli olan ve ihtiyaç duyacağı en
önemli şey nedir desek alacağımız cevap
sizce ne olacak
Su telefon başka şarj cihazı bakın
oksijene haksızlık ediyoruz
oksijen öylesine hayatımızın içini
doldurmuştur ki biz oksijenin farkında
değilizdir
ya da Güneş güneşe 3 dakika boyunca
bakamazsınız
3 dakika boyunca bakarsanız Gözleriniz
kamaşır ve gözünüzü bir başka yere
çevirmek zorunda kalırsınız bu güneşin
yokluğundan değil Bilakis çokluğundandır
Eskiden bunu çok güzel metabolize
etmişler bir cümleyle diyorlar ki
zuhurunun şiddetinden gayettir
zuhurunun şiddetinden gayettir yani o
öylesine çoktur ki öylesine Her yeri
sarmıştır ki biz onu yok kabul ederiz
bakın farkında mısınız başlıkta da
aramak unutulmuş
bulanlar kaybolanlar Peki arayanlar işte
arayanlar bizim Aslında oksijenimiz
güneşimiz gibi Evet konuşmamın teması
bulmak ve kaybolmak ama ben biraz aramak
üzerinde durmak istiyorum
Ben şu an bir tedx konuşmacısı olarak
karşınızdayım ve size bir şeyler
anlatmaya çalışıyorum Oysa ilkokulda o
kadar sessiz bir çocuktum ki
eve döndüğüm Bazı günler Dudağın
birbirine yapışmış olurdu ve o Dudağımın
birbirinden ayrılma anındaki acısını
bilirsiniz değil mi o acı O acıyla fark
ederdim ya ben bugün okulda hiç
konuşmadım dediğim günler oldu ve ben
daha ilk okuldan itibaren hep bir
Arayışın içindeydim arayışım şu; derdim
var derdimi anlatmak istiyorum insanlara
bakıyorum kendilerini çok güzel ifade
ediyorlar gülüyorlar eğleniyorlar ama
ben böyle içten içe Bunun acısını
yaşıyorum
Bu böyle devam etti
üniversiteye geldim ama nasıl kitap
okuyorum Yani bu konuşmanın özeti şu
değil Hadi gidin ve kitap okuyun Hayır
ondan bahsetmeyeceğim bir edebiyat
öğretmen olarak
kitap okuyorum Evet ve ev arkadaşlarım
film izliyorlar
ben de onlara acıyarak bak
ıyorum böyle bir bomboş eylem için
verebilirim mi acaba Yazık Günah diyorum
acıyorum ve kitap okumaya devam ediyorum
üniversite bitti Allah nasip etti
İstanbul'da bir liseye atandım
ve bir gün yine bir arayış içindeyim ama
aradığım şey ne Sanat ne ama ne edebiyat
hiçbiriyle ilgisi yok
karşıma bir cümle çıktı öğretmen temalı
Kısa Film Yarışması başladı
ne sanatla ilgim var
ne sinemayla ilgim var ne kamerayla ne
senaryo ile tamamen o alanın bedevisiyim
ama bazen şuna inanıyorum Allah insanın
içine bir şey ilham ediyor
ve arayış dedim ya
bulduğunuz zaman diyorsunuz ki Ulan bu
benim yıllardır aradığım şeymiş
diyorsunuz şimdi öğretmen temalı Kısa
Film Yarışması başladı yazısı beni
inanılmaz heyecanlandırdı Ama bakın
tekrar ediyorum sinemayla ilgili hiçbir
fikrim yok hatta düşmanı gibi bir şeyin
bir arkadaşa
dedim ki birader kameranı bana ver
ebilir mi gelemem Tamam dedim gelme Ben
başkasını ayarlarım aldım kamerayı
getirdim eve 10 of yapabiliyorum sadece
o kadar
nasıl bir cesaret Gerçekten bugün dönüp
baktığımda asla Muhtemelen Yapmayacağım
bir şey
yani yaşın da getirdiği bir şey var o
dönemde insan Tabii ki biraz daha Gözü
Kara oluyor arkadaş dedi ki ya hocam
dedi ben dedi hayatımda dedi Bir kere
kamera gördüm dedi Oğlum dedim ben onu
da görmedim gel gel sen benim işimi
görürsün geldi Biz bir kısa film çekmeye
başladık
En yakın arkadaşım oynuyor kendi
öğrencilerim oynuyor kendi okulumda
çekiyoruz yani körlerin sağırları bu
kadar iyi ağırladı çok az şey olmuştur
ortada senaryo da yok
Yani ev arkadaşıma diyorum ki kamerayı
kuruyoruz Oğlum diyorum sen şimdi şöyle
bir cümle kur o cümlesini kuruyor
diğerine geçiyor sende Sen de şöyle
cevap ver tamamen o anda senaryo
yazılıyor Çünkü yok yani senaryo nasıl
yazılır falan bilmiyorum olay ne
bir öğretmen olarak yeni atandım bir
öğrencinin
bir eşleştirmeye çalışıyordum neyse
filmi yaptık gönderdik bir gün ders
anlatıyorum telefonum çaldı Ankara'dan
geliyor telefon açtım dediler ki Ömer
Bey sizi Antalya'da ödül töreninde
ağırlamak istiyoruz biletinizi Sabiha
Gökçen'den mi alalım Atatürk'ten mi
alalım dedim ki ben öğretmenim gelemem
herkesin mi çağırıyorsunuz dedim
gittim şeyi hızlı geçiyordum İşte o
havaalanında elinde Ömer diş fırçalar
yazan adam benim canım falan oraları
hızlı geçiyor ödül töreni yaşandı işte
ben ödülü aldım sahnedeyim
ilk filmim ilk ödülüm ve üçüncü oldum bu
arada yani kişiyi ödül verdiler ama ben
3'yüm bir plaket verdiler bir çiçek
verdiler en önde oturan bir abimiz var
jüri başkanı benden önce konuşma
yapmıştı Oradan biliyorum
gel gel dedi böyle Ben dedim Yani
buradan inip onun yanına gidene
kadar böyle diyecek ki evladım Sen nasıl
bir sinema dehasısın böyle Öyle
düşünüyorum yani gittim yanına diğer
jüri üyeleri de var
dedi ki evladım Bak o el
indeki seni şımartması
neden hocam dedim tabi şey surat bir an
savaş alanına döndü neden hocam dedim
Dedi ki sinema iki şeyle kaindir bir ses
iki görüntü senin filminde ne ses vardı
Ne göründü salon buradan epeyce büyük
bir salon Yaklaşık 3 katı kadar ve dolu
dedi ki Muhtemelen dedi büyük perdede
izleyince daha net Anladım Muhtemelen
dedi Arka Taraflar komple bize küfür et
tiler jüriye nasıl bu filmi
seçer ben dedi ikna edemedim dedi jüri
başkanıyım ikna edemedim dedi orada dedi
Öyle bir şey yakalamışsın ki hikaye
yakalamışsın ki etmeyin eylemeyin
varıyorum bu film değil dememe rağmen
dedi kabul etmediler ve sana üçüncülük
ödülünü bari dedim dördüncü yapın orada
kabul etmediler üçüncü oldu ilk çek
tiğim kız neden o insanları böylesine
etkilemişti
niçindeyim ve derdimi anlatmak istiyorum
üniversite hayatım boyunca bir şeyler
karaladım işte hikayedir ne bileyim
şiirdir bir şeyler yazdım ve dergilere
gönderdim dergiler bunu bastı Ne bileyim
güzel bir şey yani hani aranızda kalem
erbabı olanlar vardır Ben de o dergileri
getirdim öğrencilerime verdim al dedim
40 kişiye yani 40 tane dergi gelmişti 40
ayrı öğrencime dağıttım dedim ki bak
dedim Şu
sayfadan Hikayem çıktı oku Yarın
konuşalım ertesi gün kırkına da tek tek
sordum okudun mu
kırk yılda okumamış
Yani bir tanesi olsa belki kafamda dönüp
durmayacak
hiç biri okumamış Neyse ben Antalya'dan
döndüm ve sinema benim için aslında
Antalya'da o
jüri Başkanlığı söyleminden sonra bitti
çünkü o söylediğinde elimdeki çiçekler
yavaş yavaş boynunu büktü solmaya
başladı falan dedim Tamam benim için
sinema bu kadarmış İstanbul'a dönerken
şeyi düşünüyorum İyi iyi yani Hayatımda
bir de sinemayı denemiş oldum okula
döndüm
bir çocuk geldi yanıma 12 sınıflardan
kalabalık bir okul tanımıyorum yani
çocuğun dersine girmiyorum
nefsiniz dedi ben dedi Onun linkine
nasıl ulaşabilirim
ne dedim
linki dedi nereden bulabiliriz
dedi Evet hocam o kadar etkilendim ki ya
benim hayatımın en büyük kırılma anı o
andır Çünkü ben hikayeye yazdığımda da
derdimi anlatmaya çalışıyordum ve
dinlemiyordum ben senin peşinde
koşuyordum Ne olur kurban olayım şunu
bir oku diyordum okumuyordum sonra adam
benim derdimi
dinlerim ki tamam sinemayla uğraşıyorum
hemen ilk seferde ilk üniversite
sınavında sınava girdim
İstanbul Üniversitesi
sinema kaydım yaptırdım ikinci
üniversite olarak sinema okumaya
başladım şimdi bu benim kabaca hayat
hikayem ve şey merak ediliyor
neydi ki o hikaye yani jüri başkanını
bile Çünkü 7-8 tane başka jüri var ve
jüri Başkanı ikna edemiyor hikaye şu
bir öğrencimiz var İsmi Tunahan okulun
en haşere öğrencilerinden bir tanesi çok
da tatlı bir çocuk ama derslere
asla derse münasebeti yok ama muhteşem
resim çiziyor inanılmaz güzel resim
çiziyor öğretmenler odasında muhabbet
Hep şu; aman bırak onu bıraktık artık ne
yaparsa yapsın
kafasını kaldırmasın yani öğretmenler
arasındaki dönem muhabbette de bu Turan
çağırdım yanıma ya bu yaşanmış bir
hikayeyi film Yaptım Yaptım filmin
hikayesini anlatıyorum
dedim ki Tuna bak Bak sürekli dedim
öğretmenler odasına sen konuşmuyorsun
benim dersinde de böyle kafanın
koyuyorsun yatıyorsun falan bak dedim
benim canımı çok Hocam dedi özür dilerim
ben dedi edebiyatı sevmiyorum Kimyayı
ise sevdiği bir ders yok Sadece resimden
hoşlanıyor dedim ki Tamam o zaman dedim
Seninle güçlerimizi birleştirebiliriz
Nasıl yani hocam dedi Dedim ki Ben dedim
Kitap okumayı çok seviyorum Sen de dedim
sen bunu çizgi roman haline getirir
misin abi o cam dediğin ne demek ayıla
bayıla yaparım gitti geliyor şimdi şey
diyor Hocam diyor 35'e kadar çizdin
bakar mısınız diyor bakıyorum tek tek
sahne sahne şeyi çiziyor kitabı çiziyor
üç gün sonra geri geliyor diyor ki hocam
diyor 95'e kadar çizdim bakıyor Oo çok
iyi Tunahan Harikasın falan gidiyor
geliyor hocam 300'e kadar içinden şey
diyorum buna Kitap okuyorsun
farkında değilsin yani benim amacım
Senin çizdiğin resim değil resimden de
anlamadım ben senin kitap okuyup okumam
anlayınla ilgileniyorum Neyse bu
hikayeyi tekrar başa dönersek kısa film
olarak çekmeye karar vermiştim ve
dediğim gibi çektim işte şeyin jüri
heyetinin hoşuna gitmiş başkanın gitmese
de dediğim gibi sinema serüveni böyle
başladı şimdi ben bütün Hepimizin
bir arayışa muhtaç olduğumuzu
düşünüyorum bulmaklarımızı
Peki niye arıyoruz niye buluyoruz ve
Niye kayboluyoruz benim bu soruya
verdiğim cevap tamamen
Münferit bir cevap Çünkü sizi
tanımıyorum hayat sizin kulağınıza
bambaşka bir şey fısıldıyor olabilir
bana şunu söyledi
bir derdin varsa o derdini anlatmak için
en doğru enstrümanı bulmak zorundasın Bu
resim olabilir bu müzik olabilir spor
olabilir Bilemiyorum yani ilgilendiğiniz
alan Her neyse Çünkü bir sözü direkt
söylemekle sanatla söylemek arasında
uçurum var arkadaşlar bilen vardır belki
Sinan Çetin'in mutlu ol bu bir emirdir
isimli bir filmi var bilmiyorum
izleyeniniz var mı tavsiye edilir O
filmde sanat aynı zamanda bir itiraz
biçimidir
bir ve bunu sanat Kilisesi altında yapar
da anlatmak istediğini o kadar iyi
anlatır ki Hiç Kimse buna itiraz edemez
yani isterdim burada açıp gidip ama
süreden yemek istemiyorum
şimdi aramak bulmak ve kaybolmak dedim
ya biz insanlar olarak Mütemadiyen
ararız Ama bu hayat Öyle garip bir
denklem ki öyle tuhaf görünmez bir Ağla
ölü ki bulduğunuz şeyin sizin için ödül
mü Ceza mı bir şeyin bedeli mi olduğunu
ancak zaman gösteriyor
bakınız
Arap yarımadasında bir dağ var
hepiniz bilirsiniz
Hira'dan manası arayış
hina dalında bir şey aradı arayan arama
süresi 40 yıl
Bulut kaybolma süresi 23 yıl
Dolayısıyla bulmak ve kaybolmak Elbette
son derece önemli ama
[Müzik]
ölene kadar
arama kıymetli
ve biz kıymetliyiz son sözümü Şeyh
galiple bağlamak istiyorum diyor ki;
hoşça bak zatına kim zübbeyi Alemsin sen
merdivenisin sen başa bakın zatınıza
[Alkış]
[Müzik]